[Music]  how do you cut down 88 million tons of  food waste a year Parliament will look  into ways of managing on soul food and  encouraging food operators to donate  them in recent years the EU has had to  review an tighten its policy of  returning light risk we don't need  conditions of staying in Europe a new  action plan will be debated should you  conversations on whatsapp Facebook all  scarred be better protected any Peas  we'll delve into the many facets of  privacy the atomic grain ships train or  bus chances are unmanned is in the  driver's seat a hearing will explore  opportunities for women and how they can  help fill the need for qualified staff  one in three girls under 18 is forced  into marriage and developing countries  any peas and experts will discuss this  widespread problem